um I'm curious man because you guys all
have very uh unique Journeys obviously
both of y'all were on drive for a very
long time
um Cube you've been a major label artist
you've gone independent nowadays it
feels like the transparency of record
deals is higher people are talking about
it more in terms of like some of these
shitty deals that are getting offered
our Meek Mill's talked about it a lot
recently
um what is your guys's like uh thoughts
on just like where the game is and like
artists becoming a lot more self-aware
on some of the deals they're signing
because I'm assuming like everybody's
probably signed a deal that they're not
the craziest about you know what I mean
and you guys have seen all sides of the
game whether it's doing the independent
[ __ ] doing the major label [ __ ]
well you know um my Westmore we're doing
it like one at a time so uh we're not
really like uh getting buried up under
contracts or anything anything like that
we we definitely um the group is
definitely grossed quite a bit of money
before any anything ever drives well the
tour's been going you guys yeah doing a
lot of tour dates shows we did really
good on merch we did um really good with
uh you know some early stuff we did like
we appeared at the trailer event when
Jake I remember that yeah that was a big
payday and you know we just kind of is
that the same fight um Nate Robinson
took the uh no no it was the one after
right it was one before he took the he
took the L before that fight I believe I
can't remember but it was it was yeah
and I remember that was it was in
Atlanta you guys have been building this
for I mean big subwoofers been out over
a year so yeah so it's like a it's like
a business play man everything is
thought out in advance when we gonna
drop the album when's the next album
coming where the division was going to
do like you know what's the next money
place it's more like a business and I
think that um I think that this
market right now for a young artists
they don't have to just go sign to a
major label and get buried or do a 360
deal they could really like go do deals
with different platforms and different
type of spaces where the music could
live is so much it's so many different
places in a song or an album a project
can go right now so you know you gotta
just Factor all that in and not just do
that old conventional one street you
know like get into the physical you
can't do that like you got to do a lot
of stuff so I think um it's a good time
to like uh you know we got good leverage
on this being is that a snooping Cube 40
is short and we owe G's and we solid we
don't have we didn't have to go in there
and they're like well I'll give you a
deal but you got to sign off for like
seven albums like we it went out with us
what would you Cube what would you uh
advise like a younger artist who's maybe
got like a like a solid local Buzz they
get you would you would you
you know give them advice to explore the
major label route or or try to stay as
independent as long as possible stay as
independent as long as possible as long
as you can
you know when you do your music without
a record label
you own a hundred percent of it
and once you sign with a record label
you you basically giving them
a percentage of your work so if you have
the
the discipline
and the resources
to be an independent artist then you
should do it a lot of guys are and I let
40 speak on it but a lot of guys are
um
you know they signed 360 deals and
that's like one of the worst deals ever
invented in man so
um some of them start you know you get
real educated on deals once you sign a
bad one because you realize why why the
money is not making it to me yeah well I
haven't gotten any royalty checks it's
almost like the last check you ever see
is the advance so they they start to you
know nothing will teach you more
about the music business than signing a
bad deal and you
figuring out why it's bad right then you
become an expert and uh I'll kick it
over to 40 to you know give a few
comments on it well nowadays you know
um the new uh era the new generation has
it pretty damn good and I'm happy for
them and they smart a lot of these
youngsters are smart they don't have to
sign with a major a major give you the
good if you like I can't I can't really
put a
age group I'm not talking to the mic I
can't put an age on it but just say you
just say you're 18 or 19. and you signed
a deal for three years and that label
blow you up
it might be it might be good for you it
might be like they put they put the
whole house behind you that might be
cool right because that's what you need
because you know how to the the funding
for it
um the financials for you don't have you
don't have it so you you know you let
you let them you know do what they need
to do with you
um be smarter and make sure that um
you know you negotiate your Masters and
all that stuff you know how quick you
get them back and whatnot you know what
I'm saying but
that can be a that could be an advantage
for you
um if you're really young
you know I mean and because because then
once you get off that label then you got
the visual kids of the world and just
distribution deals you know 90 10 and
you know what I'm saying those type of
Foundations yeah that kind of stuff you
know and that way you can control your
own destiny and you're getting all the
gouda you understand me um you keep your
bastards right you keep your Masters
careful yeah because
it could go the other way too some
people sign you and they don't do [ __ ]
yeah you go out there and do all the
work and they get paid you care about
yourself right and now they then they
come out the world right and won't want
they cut and you feel like man y'all
ain't do nothing but so you got to just
be careful you got to really know who
you getting in business with and and not
just be happy to be signed yeah but
understand that this is a business a lot
of Minds a lot of land mines in the
major industry in the major label
industry with uh
come in that door with those smiles and
those meetings and they bring out the
whole staff and it's like catering and
they love you and they sell it yeah and
the check is big and you happy you're
celebrating and the product comes out
and it does whatever but somewhere you
know when I say landmines you can't
really get mad at the right person right
you call up there yelling and screaming
they're gonna Shuffle you you go up
there acting an ass they gonna Shuffle
you you sit there and your next single
come out on your second album and it's
Stellar they gonna Shuffle you and it's
like you're still a really good artist
and you get a lot of really good artists
lost in that major label sauce so if you
go there know what you're doing stay
independent you in charge of it you stay
in you stay independent you know that's
nothing that's an advantage I had over
many people that started off on major
labels I was independent for many moons
I was Independence six years before I
even you know unsigned my major
distribution deal into 20 into 1994 with
Jive I I came in the game in 1988
independent so it was six years I had to
you know to I went to college to learn
when I say college I'm talking about
just music industry College you know
unwillingly you know what it says I just
went because I had to learn I was in it
by force not by choice so then when I
signed my distribution deal was great
because I I already had the demand you
know understand I knew what I wanted and
it was great so I'm independent still
right now
um I control my own destiny but my whole
thing is is this nowadays you could do
what the majors do as a as an
independent Young artist all you got to
do is hire Indies and you can hire Indie
radio people yep you know it's all kind
of stuff you can do and it's really up
to you you can you can promote yourself
it's like a la carte menu social media
is there content all that work your
content on the social media is the
biggest platform you're director
consumer now exactly you needed a deal
to get into the record store now you're
locked in you don't have to press up
hard CDs and all that stuff you just you
could we can go in there right right now
make a song right now today right now
let's put the beat up make a slap had it
[ __ ] on iTunes in 24 hours